especially when combined with deep
neural networks
but for this class of algorithms
very little is known from a theoretical
perspective
even in very simple problem settings
so that's going to be the focus of this
work
uh and so considering a markov decision
process with some state
and action space uh the goal in
reinforcement learning is to find an
optimal policy
that sort of minimizes the the cost to
go
uh simultaneously from all states
and sort of what these policy-grade
methods do is that they consider
this scalar objective n which just
averages this cost to go
under some initial distribution and they
search over a parameterized class of
policies by doing a stochastic gradient
descent
so next slide please
and uh one of the the main challenge
with analyzing policy grade methods is
this this
objective is uh almost always
non-convex so even for very very simple
problems like uh finite state and action
mdps
uh you can show that this uh the
the policy and objective is non-convex
and this is sort of a fundamental issue
because uh we are minimizing the cost to
go which is fundamentally
a multi-period objective and so our
conventional understanding has been that
because first-order methods are
similarly
asymptotically converged to stationary
points but there is no
uh guarantee of the quality of these
stationary points
next slide
so in this work we take a step towards
that
and we consider an idealized setting
where we have access to exact gradients
uh we assume that the initial
distribution row
provides sufficient exploration so there
are no challenges uh
with exploration and we
assume the the policy class contains the
optimal policy
uh and under this we identify some
structural properties which guarantee
that the
policy gradient objective has no sub
optimal stationary points
and under some stricter versions of
these properties
we can show that this objective is also
gradient dominated
so so taken together we can show
asymptotically asymptotic convergence of
policy gradient methods to the optimal
policy
and under slightly stronger conditions
we can also
also show gradient dominance which
implies our convergence rates
next slide
and finally uh our results apply to many
uh classical control problems
uh for example finite state action mdps
with the class of policies
over the simplex linear quadratic
control problems
with the class of linear policies
optimal stopping problems with the class
of threshold
policies and we also have extensions
to finite horizon inventory control
problems
the class of non-stationary